ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
le pétrole est absolument partout dans
nos vies aujourd'hui sans le pétrole il
y aurait pas eu le 20e siècle et à
forceori pas le début du 21e le pétrole
est dans ce qu'on mange enfin pétrole et
gaz parce que nous mangeons des choses
qui ont été cultivées avec des tracteurs
fertilisé avec des engrais et défendus
contre les petites bestioles avec des
phytosanitaires tout ça c'est du pétrole
le pétrole est dans nos vêtements parce
que toutes les fibres en polymachin
chouette que nous avons sur nous et le
nylon ça c'est du pétrole et même quand
c'est du coton ce qui le cas de mon
t-shirt il a été teint avec du pétrole
transporter avec du pétrole assembler
avec du pétrole le pétrole est dans le
système mondial de transport et
notamment les camions et les bateaux et
sans les camions et les bateau vous
auriez en France plus une casserole plus
un téléphone ce qui serait beaucoup plus
grave que les casseroles plus une caméra
pour nous filmer et plus un bout de
moquette il est absolument partout le
pétrole on se rend pas compte mais il
est absolument partout il y a pas un
truc qu'on fasse dans la journée auquel
on y échappe il est dans les rouges à
lèvres et les cosmétiques il enfin
absolument
partout